Last time we saw things about
gradients and directional
derivatives.
Before that we studied how to
look for minima and maxima of
functions of several variables.
And today we are going to look
again at min/max problems but in
a different setting,
namely, one for variables that
are not independent.
And so what we will see is you
may have heard of Lagrange
multipliers.
And this is the one point in
the term when I can shine with
my French accent and say
Lagrange's name properly.
OK.
What are Lagrange multipliers
about?
Well, the goal is to minimize
or maximize a function of
several variables.
Let's say, for example,
f of x, y, z,
but where these variables are
no longer independent.
They are not independent.
That means that there is a
relation between them.
The relation is maybe some
equation of the form g of x,
y, z equals some constant.
You take the relation between
x, y, z, you call that g and
that gives you the constraint.
And your goal is to minimize f
only of those values of x,
y, z that satisfy the
constraint.
What is one way to do that?
Well, one to do that,
if the constraint is very
simple, we can maybe solve for
one of the variables.
Maybe we can solve this
equation for one of the
variables, plug it back into f,
and then we have a usual
min/max problem that we have
seen how to do.
The problem is sometimes you
cannot actually solve for x,
y, z in here because this
condition is too complicated and
then we need a new method.
That is what we are going to do.
Why would we care about that?
Well, one example is actually
in physics.
Maybe you have seen in
thermodynamics that you study
quantities about gases,
and those quantities that
involve pressure,
volume and temperature.
And pressure,
volume and temperature are not
independent of each other.
I mean you know probably the
equation PV = NRT.
And, of course,
there you could actually solve
to express things in terms of
one or the other.
But sometimes it is more
convenient to keep all three
variables but treat them as
constrained.
It is just an example of a
situation where you might want
to do this.
Anyway, we will look mostly at
particular examples,
but just to point out that this
is useful when you study guesses
in physics.
The first observation is we
cannot use our usual method of
looking for critical points of
f.
Because critical points of f
typically will not satisfy this
condition and so won't be good
solutions.
We need something else.
Let's look at an example,
and we will see how that leads
us to the method.
For example,
let's say that I want to find
the point closest to the origin
-- -- on the hyperbola xy equals
3 in the plane.
That means I have this
hyperbola, and I am asking
myself what is the point on it
that is the closest to the
origin?
I mean we can solve this by
elementary geometry,
we don't need actually Lagrange
multipliers,
but we are going to do it with
Lagrange multipliers because it
is a pretty good example.
What does it mean?
Well, it means that we want to
minimize distance to the origin.
What is the distance to the
origin?
If I have a point,
at coordinates (x,
y) and then the distance to the
origin is square root of x
squared plus y squared.
Well, do we really want to
minimize that or can we minimize
something easier?
Yeah.
Maybe we can minimize the
square of a distance.
Let's forget this guy and
instead -- Actually,
we will minimize f of x,
y equals x squared plus y
squared,
that looks better,
subject to the constraint xy =
3.
And so we will call this thing
g of x, y to illustrate the
general method.
Let's look at a picture.
Here you can see in yellow the
hyperbola xy equals three.
And we are going to look for
the points that are the closest
to the origin.
What can we do?
Well, for example,
we can plot the function x
squared plus y squared,
function f.
That is the contour plot of f
with a hyperbola on top of it.
Now let's see what we can do
with that.
Well, let's ask ourselves,
for example,
if I look at points where f
equals 20 now.
I think I am at 20 but you
cannot really see it.
That is a circle with a point
whose distant square is 20.
Well, can I find a solution if
I am on the hyperbola?
Yes, there are four points at
this distance.
Can I do better?
Well, let's decrease for
distance.
Yes, we can still find points
on the hyperbola and so on.
Except if we go too low then
there are no points on this
circle anymore in the hyperbola.
If we decrease the value of f
that we want to look at that
will somehow limit value beyond
which we cannot go,
and that is the minimum of f.
We are trying to look for the
smallest value of f that will
actually be realized on the
hyperbola.
When does that happen?
Well, I have to backtrack a
little bit.
It seems like the limiting case
is basically here.
It is when the circle is
tangent to the hyperbola.
That is the smallest circle
that will hit the hyperbola.
If I take a larger value of f,
I will have solutions.
If I take a smaller value of f,
I will not have any solutions
anymore.
So, that is the situation that
we want to solve for.
How do we find that minimum?
Well, a key observation that is
valid on this picture,
and that actually remain true
in the completely general case,
is that when we have a minimum
the level curve of f is actually
tangent to our hyperbola.
It is tangent to the set of
points where x,
y equals three,
to the hyperbola.
Let's write that down.
We observe that at the minimum
the level curve of f is tangent
to the hyperbola.
Remember, the hyperbola is
given by the equal g equals
three, so it is a level curve of
g.
We have a level curve of f and
a level curve of g that are
tangent to each other.
And I claim that is going to be
the general situation that we
are interested in.
How do we try to solve for
points where this happens?
How do we find x,
y where the level curves of f
and g are tangent to each other?
Let's think for a second.
If the two level curves are
tangent to each other that means
they have the same tangent line.
That means that the normal
vectors should be parallel.
Let me maybe draw a picture
here.
This is the level curve maybe f
equals something.
And this is the level curve g
equals constant.
Here my constant is three.
Well, if I look for gradient
vectors, the gradient of f will
be perpendicular to the level
curve of f.
The gradient of g will be
perpendicular to the level curve
of g.
They don't have any reason to
be of the same size,
but they have to be parallel to
each other.
Of course, they could also be
parallel pointing in opposite
directions.
But the key point is that when
this happens the gradient of f
is parallel to the gradient of
g.
Well, let's check that.
Here is a point.
And I can plot the gradient of
f in blue.
The gradient of g in yellow.
And you see,
in most of these places,
somehow the two gradients are
not really parallel.
Actually, I should not be
looking at random points.
I should be looking only on the
hyperbola.
I want points on the hyperbola
where the two gradients are
parallel.
Well, when does that happen?
Well, it looks like it will
happen here.
When I am at a minimum,
the two gradient vectors are
parallel.
It is not really proof.
It is an example that seems to
be convincing.
So far things work pretty well.
How do we decide if two vectors
are parallel?
Well, they are parallel when
they are proportional to each
other.
You can write one of them as a
constant times the other one,
and that constant usually one
uses the Greek letter lambda.
I don't know if you have seen
it before.
It is the Greek letter for L.
And probably,
I am sure, it is somebody's
idea of paying tribute to
Lagrange by putting an L in
there.
Lambda is just a constant.
And we are looking for a scalar
lambda and points x and y where
this holds.
In fact,
what we are doing is replacing
min/max problems in two
variables with a constraint
between them by a set of
equations involving,
you will see, three variables.
We had min/max with two
variables x, y,
but no independent.
We had a constraint g of x,
y equals constant.
And that becomes something new.
That becomes a system of
equations where we have to
solve, well, let's write down
what it means for gradient f to
be proportional to gradient g.
That means that f sub x should
be lambda times g sub x,
and f sub y should be lambda
times g sub y.
Because the gradient vectors
here are f sub x,
f sub y and g sub x,
g sub y.
If you have a third variable z
then you have also an equation f
sub z equals lambda g sub z.
Now, let's see.
How many unknowns do we have in
these equations?
Well, there is x,
there is y and there is lambda.
We have three unknowns and have
only two equations.
Something is missing.
Well, I mean x and y are not
actually independent.
They are related by the
equation g of x,
y equals c, so we need to add
the constraint g equals c.
And now we have three equations
involving three variables.
Let's see how that works.
Here remember we have f equals
x squared y squared and g = xy.
What is f sub x?
It is going to be 2x equals
lambda times,
what is g sub x,
y.
Maybe I should write here f sub
x equals lambda g sub x just to
remind you.
Then we have f sub y equals
lambda g sub y.
F sub y is 2y equals lambda
times g sub y is x.
And then our third equation g
equals c becomes xy equals
three.
So, that is what you would have
to solve.
Any questions at this point?
No.
Yes?
How do I know the direction of
a gradient?
Do you mean how do I know that
it is perpendicular to a level
curve?
Oh, how do I know if it points
in that direction on the
opposite one?
Well, that depends.
I mean we'd seen in last time,
but the gradient is
perpendicular to the level and
points towards higher values of
a function.
So it could be -- Wait.
What did I have?
It could be that my gradient
vectors up there actually point
in opposite directions.
It doesn't matter to me because
it will still look the same in
terms of the equation,
just lambda will be positive or
negative, depending on the case.
I can handle both situations.
It's not a problem.
I can allow lambda to be
positive or negative.
Well, in this example,
it looks like lambda will be
positive.
If you look at the picture on
the plot.
Yes?
Well, because actually they are
not equal to each other.
If you look at this point where
the hyperbola and the circle
touch each other,
first of all,
I don't know which circle I am
going to look at.
I am trying to solve,
actually, for the radius of the
circle.
I am trying to find what the
minimum value of f is.
And, second,
at that point,
the value of f and the value of
g are not equal.
g is equal to three because I
want the hyperbola x equals
three.
The value of f will be the
square of a distance,
whatever that is.
I think it will end up being 6,
but we will see.
So, you cannot really set them
equal because you don't know
what f is equal to in advance.
Yes?
Not quite.
Actually, here I am just using
this idea of finding a point
closest to the origin to
illustrate an example of a
min/max problem.
The general problem we are
trying to solve is minimize f
subject to g equals constant.
And what we are going to do for
that is we are really going to
say instead let's look at places
where gradient f and gradient g
are parallel to each other and
solve for equations of that.
I think we completely lose the
notion of closest point if we
just look at these equations.
We don't really say anything
about closest points anymore.
Of course, that is what they
mean in the end.
But, in the general setting,
there is no closest point
involved anymore.
OK.
Yes?
Yes.
It is always going to be the
case that,
at the minimum,
or at the maximum of a function
subject to a constraint,
the level curves of f and the
level curves of g will be
tangent to each other.
That is the basis for this
method.
I am going to justify that soon.
It could be minimum or maximum.
In three-dimensions it could
even be a saddle point.
And, in fact,
I should say in advance,
this method will not tell us
whether it is a minimum or a
maximum.
We do not have any way of
knowing, except for testing
values.
We cannot use second derivative
tests or anything like that.
I will get back to that.
Yes?
Yes.
Here you can set y equals to
favor x.
Then you can minimize x squared
plus nine over x squared.
In general, if I am trying to
solve a more complicated
problem, I might not be able to
solve.
I am doing an example where,
indeed, here you could solve
and remove one variable,
but you cannot always do that.
And this method will still work.
The other one won't.
OK.
I don't see any other questions.
Are there any other questions?
No.
OK.
I see a lot of students
stretching and so on,
so it is very confusing for me.
How do we solve these equations?
Well, the answer is in general
we might be in deep trouble.
There is no general method for
solving the equations that you
get from this method.
You just have to think about
them.
Sometimes it will be very easy.
Sometimes it will be so hard
that you cannot actually do it
without the computer.
Sometimes it will be just hard
enough to be on Part B of this
week's problem set.
I claim in this case we can
actually do it without so much
trouble, because actually we can
think of this as a two by two
linear system in x and y.
Well, let me do something.
Let me rewrite the first two
equations as 2x - lambda y = 0.
And lambda x - 2y = 0.
And xy = 3.
That is what we want to solve.
Well, I can put this into
matrix form.
Two minus lambda,
lambda minus two times x,
y equals 0,0.
Now, how do I solve a linear
system matrix times x,
y equals zero?
Well, I always have an obvious
solution.
X and y both equal to zero.
Is that a good solution?
No, because zero times zero is
not three.
We want another solution,
the trivial solution.
0,0 does not solve the
constraint equation xy equals
three, so we want another
solution.
When do we have another
solution?
Well, when the determinant of a
matrix is zero.
We have other solutions that
exist only if determinant of a
matrix is zero.
M is this guy.
Let's compute the determinant.
Well, that seems to be negative
four plus lambda squared.
That is zero exactly when
lambda squared equals four,
which is lambda is plus or
minus two.
Already you see here it is a
the level of difficulty that is
a little bit much for an exam
but perfectly fine for a problem
set or for a beautiful lecture
like this one.
How do we deal with -- Well,
we have two cases to look at.
Lambda equals two or lambda
equals minus two.
Let's start with lambda equals
two.
If I set lambda equals two,
what does this equation become?
Well, it becomes x equals y.
This one becomes y equals x.
Well, they seem to be the same.
x equals y.
And then the equation xy equals
three becomes,
well, x squared equals three.
I have two solutions.
One is x equals root three and,
therefore, y equals root three
as well, or negative root three
and negative root three.
Let's look at the other case.
If I set lambda equal to
negative two then I get 2x
equals negative 2y.
That means x equals negative y.
The second one,
2y equals negative 2x.
That is y equals negative x.
Well, that is the same thing.
And xy equals three becomes
negative x squared equals three.
Can we solve that?
No.
There are no solutions here.
Now we have two candidate
points which are these two
points, root three,
root three or negative root
three, negative root three.
OK.
Let's actually look at what we
have here.
Maybe you cannot read the
coordinates, but the point that
I have here is indeed root
three, root three.
How do we see that lambda
equals two?
Well, if you look at this
picture, the gradient of f,
that is the blue vector,
is indeed twice the yellow
vector, gradient g.
That is where you read the
value of lambda.
And we have the other solution
which is somewhere here.
Negative root three,
negative root there.
And there, again,
lambda equals two.
The two vectors are
proportional by a factor of two.
Yes?
No, solutions are not quite
guaranteed to be absolute minima
or maxima.
They are guaranteed to be
somehow critical points end of a
constraint.
That means if you were able to
solve and eliminate the variable
that would be a critical point.
When you have the same problem,
as we have critical points,
are they maxima or minima?
And the answer is,
well, we won't know until we
check.
More questions?
No.
Yes?
What is a Lagrange multiplier?
Well, it is this number lambda
that is called the multiplier
here.
It is a multiplier because it
is what you have to multiply
gradient of g by to get gradient
of f.
It multiplies.
Let's try to see why is this
method valid?
Because so far I have shown you
pictures and have said see they
are tangent.
But why is it that they have to
be tangent in general?
Let's think about it.
Let's say that we are at
constrained min or max.
What that means is that if I
move on the level g equals
constant then the value of f
should only increase or only
decrease.
But it means,
in particular,
to first order it will not
change.
At an unconstrained min or max,
partial derivatives are zero.
In this case,
derivatives are zero only in
the allowed directions.
And the allowed directions are
those that stay on the levels of
this g equals constant.
In any direction along the
level set g = c the rate of
change of f must be zero.
That is what happens at minima
or maxima.
Except here,
of course, we look only at the
allowed directions.
Let's say the same thing in
terms of directional
derivatives.
That means for any direction
that is tangent to the
constraint level g equal c,
we must have df over ds in the
direction of u equals zero.
I will draw a picture.
Let's say now I am in three
variables just to give you
different examples.
Here I have a level surface g
equals c.
I am at my point.
And if I move in any direction
that is on the level surface,
so I move in the direction u
tangent to the level surface,
then the rate of change of f in
that direction should be zero.
Now, remember what the formula
is for this guy.
Well, we have seen that this
guy is actually radiant f dot u.
That means any such vector u
must be perpendicular to the
gradient of f.
That means that the gradient of
f should be perpendicular to
anything that is tangent to this
level.
That means the gradient of f
should be perpendicular to the
level set.
That is what we have shown.
But we know another vector that
is also perpendicular to the
level set of g.
That is the gradient of g.
We conclude that the gradient
of f must be parallel to the
gradient of g because both are
perpendicular to the level set
of g.
I see confused faces,
so let me try to tell you again
where that comes from.
We said if we had a constrained
minimum or maximum,
if we move in the level set of
g, f doesn't change.
Well, it doesn't change to
first order.
It is the same idea as when you
are looking for a minimum you
set the derivative equal to
zero.
So the derivative in any
direction, tangent to g equals
c, should be the directional
derivative of f,
in any such direction,
should be zero.
That is what we mean by
critical point of f.
And so that means that any
vector u, any unit vector
tangent to the level set of g is
going to be perpendicular to the
gradient of f.
That means that the gradient of
f is perpendicular to the level
set of g.
If you want,
that means the level sets of f
and g are tangent to each other.
That is justifying what we have
observed in the picture that the
two level sets have to be
tangent to each other at the
prime minimum or maximum.
Does that make a little bit of
sense?
Kind of.
I see at least a few faces
nodding so I take that to be a
positive answer.
Since I have been asked by
several of you,
how do I know if it is a
maximum or a minimum?
Well, warning,
the method doesn't tell whether
a solution is a minimum or a
maximum.
How do we do it?
Well, more bad news.
We cannot use the second
derivative test.
And the reason for that is that
we care actually only about
these specific directions that
are tangent to variable of g.
And we don't want to bother to
try to define directional second
derivatives.
Not to mention that actually it
wouldn't work.
There is a criterion but it is
much more complicated than that.
Basically, the answer for us is
that we don't have a second
derivative test in this
situation.
What are we left with?
Well, we are just left with
comparing values.
Say that in this problem you
found a point where f equals
three, a point where f equals
nine, a point where f equals 15.
Well, then probably the minimum
is the point where f equals
three and the maximum is 15.
Actually, in this case,
where we found minima,
these two points are tied for
minimum.
What about the maximum?
What is the maximum of f on the
hyperbola?
Well, it is infinity because
the point can go as far as you
want from the origin.
But the general idea is if we
have a good reason to believe
that there should be a minimum,
and it's not like at infinity
or something weird like that,
then the minimum will be a
solution of the Lagrange
multiplier equations.
We just look for all the
solutions and then we choose the
one that gives us the lowest
value.
Is that good enough?
Let me actually write that down.
To find the minimum or the
maximum, we compare values of f
at the various solutions -- --
to Lagrange multiplier
equations.
I should say also that
sometimes you can just conclude
by thinking geometrically.
In this case,
when it is asking you which
point is closest to the origin
you can just see that your
answer is the correct one.
Let's do an advanced example.
Advanced means that -- Well,
this one I didn't actually dare
to put on top of the other
problem sets.
Instead, I am going to do it.
What is this going to be about?
We are going to look for a
surface minimizing pyramid.
Let's say that we want to build
a pyramid with a given
triangular base -- -- and a
given volume.
Say that I have maybe in the x,
y plane I am giving you some
triangle.
And I am going to try to build
a pyramid.
Of course, I can choose where
to put the top of a pyramid.
This guy will end up being
behind now.
And the constraint and the goal
is to minimize the total surface
area.
The first time I taught this
class, it was a few years ago,
was just before they built the
Stata Center.
And then I used to motivate
this problem by saying Frank
Gehry has gone crazy and has
been given a triangular plot of
land he wants to put a pyramid.
There needs to be the right
amount of volume so that you can
put all the offices in there.
And he wants it to be,
actually, covered in solid
gold.
And because that is expensive,
the administration wants him to
cut the costs a bit.
And so you have to minimize the
total size so that it doesn't
cost too much.
We will see if MIT comes up
with a triangular pyramid
building.
Hopefully not.
It could be our next dorm,
you never know.
Anyway, it is a fine geometry
problem.
Let's try to think about how we
can do this.
The natural way to think about
it would be -- Well,
what do we have to look for
first?
We have to look for the
position of that top point.
Remember we know that the
volume of a pyramid is one-third
the area of base times height.
In fact, fixing the volume,
knowing that we have fixed the
area of a base,
means that we are fixing the
height of the pyramid.
The height is completely fixed.
What we have to choose just is
where do we put that top point?
Do we put it smack in the
middle of a triangle or to a
side or even anywhere we want?
Its z coordinate is fixed.
Let's call h the height.
What we could do is something
like this.
We say we have three points of
a base.
Let's call them p1 at (x1,
y1,0); p2 at (x2,
y2,0); p3 at (x3,
y3,0).
This point p is the unknown
point at (x, y,
h).
We know the height.
And then we want to minimize
the sum of the areas of these
three triangles.
One here, one here and one at
the back.
And areas of triangles we know
how to express by using length
of cross-product.
It becomes a function of x and
y.
And you can try to minimize it.
Actually, it doesn't quite work.
The formulas are just too
complicated.
You will never get there.
What happens is actually maybe
we need better coordinates.
Why do we need better
coordinates?
That is because the geometry is
kind of difficult to do if you
use x, y coordinates.
I mean formula for
cross-product is fine,
but then the length of the
vector will be annoying and just
doesn't look good.
Instead, let's think about it
differently.
I claim if we do it this way
and we express the area as a
function of x,
y, well, actually we can't
solve for a minimum.
Here is another way to do it.
Well, what has worked pretty
well for us so far is this
geometric idea of base times
height.
So let's think in terms of the
heights of side triangles.
I am going to use the height of
these things.
And I am going to say that the
area will be the sum of three
terms, which are three bases
times three heights.
Let's give names to these
quantities.
Actually, for that it is going
to be good to have the point in
the xy plane that lives directly
below p.
Let's call it q.
P is the point that coordinates
x, y, h.
And let's call q the point that
is just below it and so it'
coordinates are x,
y, 0.
Let's see.
Let me draw a map of this thing.
p1, p2, p3 and I have my point
q in the middle.
Let's see.
To know these areas,
I need to know the base.
Well, the base I can decide
that I know it because it is
part of my given data.
I know the sides of this
triangle.
Let me call the lengths a1,
a2, a3.
I also need to know the height,
so I need to know these
lengths.
How do I know these lengths?
Well, its distance in space,
but it is a little bit
annoying.
But maybe I can reduce it to a
distance in the plane by looking
instead at this distance here.
Let me give names to the
distances from q to the sides.
Let's call u1,
u2, u3 the distances from q to
the sides.
Well, now I can claim I can
find, actually,
sorry.
I need to draw one more thing.
I claim I have a nice formula
for the area,
because this is vertical and
this is horizontal so this
length here is u3,
this length here is h.
So what is this length here?
It is the square root of u3
squared plus h squared.
And similarly for these other
guys.
They are square roots of a u
squared plus h squared.
The heights of the faces are
square root of u1 squared times
h squared.
And similarly with u2 and u3.
So the total side area is going
to be the area of the first
faces,
one-half of base times height,
plus one-half of a base times a
height plus one-half of the
third one.
It doesn't look so much better.
But, trust me,
it will get better.
Now, that is a function of
three variables,
u1, u2, u3.
And how do we relate u1,
u2, u3 to each other?
They are probably not
independent.
Well, let's cut this triangle
here into three pieces like
that.
Then each piece has side --
Well, let's look at it the piece
of the bottom.
It has base a3, height u3.
Cutting base into three tells
you that the area of a base is
one-half of a1,
u1 plus one-half of a2,
u2 plus one-half of a3,
u3.
And that is our constraint.
My three variables,
u1, u2, u3, are constrained in
this way.
The sum of this figure must be
the area of a base.
And I want to minimize that guy.
So that is my g and that guy
here is my f.
Now we try to apply our
Lagrange multiplier equations.
Well, partial f of a partial u1
is -- Well,
if you do the calculation,
you will see it is one-half a1,
u1 over square root of u1^2
plus h^2 equals lambda,
what is partial g,
partial a1?
That one you can do, I am sure.
It is one-half a1.
Oh, these guys simplify.
If you do the same with the
second one -- -- things simplify
again.
And the same with the third one.
Well, you will get,
after simplifying,
u3 over square root of u3
squared plus h squared equals
lambda.
Now, that means this guy equals
this guy equals this guy.
They are all equal to lambda.
And, if you think about it,
that means that u1 = u2 = u3.
See, it looked like scary
equations but the solution is
very simple.
What does it mean?
It means that our point q
should be equidistant from all
three sides.
That is called the incenter.
Q should be in the incenter.
The next time you have to build
a golden pyramid and don't want
to go broke, well,
you know where to put the top.
If that was a bit fast, sorry.
Anyway, it is not completely
crucial.
But go over it and you will see
it works.
Have a nice weekend.